I would probably do that hey just the
tip
let me stick the tip in
just yeah that's a weird thing with your
fingernails
yeah right finger girl you're just like
just the tip you think it's the French
you know if you think any guy that says
I'm just gonna stick the tip in the only
stuck it in or do you think this is why
I've always allowed guys to it's a trick
just do the tip yeah and I hold them to
it because all of for me all of my
sensory my nerve the feelings the good
sensation is in the beginning part of
the vagina I don't feel [__] when it's
way up there why not there's nothing
there it's just the thing it's just the
back of me it's no man's land yeah it's
just the back of me it's just the back
of me it's the front of my back
that really is the farthest back in the
vaginal cavity is the front of my back
we got it guys we did it we did it now
that's a podcast
but it's even like so cute what's a
silky soaking is when you just stick it
in but you just keep it in there it's
very like Mormon and it's oh docking
right it's soaking no but the docking is
when you put your penis against another
penis oh my bad no it's our bad
yeah yeah
the two foreskins go over each other he
would know it oh no I used to dock my
own finger when I was younger wait how
does that work so that's two four skins
is it like oh I know it's like an avatar
where you when they when they connect
with the navi with the leaves and other
animals that little thing that they have
is that what docking is yeah wow but you
do with penis I will do it can you
exchange information like an avatar your
eyes roll back yes okay good that's cool
what a gift
what a gift if you could dock with
somebody like you know you know the
Vulcans and Star Trek they can mind meld
yeah right so it's basically if you talk
with another man that you see weren't
circumcised you can live their past yeah
wow that's amazing that's amazing that's
cool you can go all the way back to them
not getting circumcised
yes yes yeah yeah that's interesting but
let me ask you to say when you talk and
let me yeah this is a valid question and
if you come is that gay
no that's actually how you uh make the
working force can stick oh that's the
adhesive it's adhesive yeah I didn't
know I walk around with that right yeah
it's gonna fall off it's like the
refried beans and the tacos and stuff
when they make in the double double
crochet double decker chocolate yeah the
double ticker chocolate they use the
refried beans as an adhesive but if you
use calm when you dock you dock it wow
the science yeah yeah so that's not gay
but if you're a wreck it's okay you need
to be a wrecked yeah oh so it's a dog
you have to be a rat it's almost gay if
you're not a wrecked oh that's unless
you do a silk dog what's a snake dog
your dick in the dock okay
[Laughter]
oh
I love it I love whenever he goes
he doesn't really know he just does that
to get move on no does he do that is
that one of your catchphrase oh for sure
yeah yeah that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool catchphrata
it's like pretty good yeah it's pretty
good can you talk in a butthole that's
just [__] an ass no can you soak in a
butthole you can still soak it up all
soaking is is that you have to resist
the urge to pump so you're just putting
it in and then not moving yeah if I soak
in another man's butthole and I don't
pump is that gay it's no because it's
not gay it's not gay and you know what
you're resting I'm resting right right
long journey hibernating like a bear oh
yeah it's true it's not gay you're just
taking a rest inside of an [__]
yeah hibernate and if you did it for six
months then it would be probably true
yeah yeah but that'd be weird to walk
around anyway um so anyway yeah so I
like doing stand-up probably more than
you do and you're never gonna come back
to LA
I know I definitely won't ever live in
Los Angeles but I have an apartment here
that's just amazing you guys should come
over for dinner sometime really you do
we have this incredible view it's right
behind the Hollywood